- For me success is
about the impact you make
and what, kind of, legacy
that you leave behind.
Say, how many people used
what you created, what
the benefit is overall.
More than just financial success, I feel
it's really is more
about making a difference
in people's lives and
to the world as a whole.
I'm managing part in
the collegiate capital,
which is a venture capital
fund and company pull builder.
We're part VC, part start-up.
And more than just writing checks,
our goal is really to help start-ups
in every stage of the journey.
So whether it's technical
support, legal support,
accounting, international expansion,
hiring corporate, exedra.
So actually really adding extra value
beyond just a few meetings
and a check, which is a problem
I feel with a lot of the
Venture Capital industry at the moment.
(motivational music)
I started my first company at 16.
Since then I've been doing lots of stuff
and kind of creating my
own companies, getting work
experience, working in finance.
While in doing contractor full time
after graduating straight away.
And actually joined black
broke and get the experience
and then run my companies
on the side so I had the
chance to do some banking and consulting,
I chose asset management
because it turns out
this market gives you the
freedom, once you've left
the office, to actually
do things in the evening.
At the same time you get
that experience, you get
that credibility as well from
working in a large company.
You get that training.
A lot of people think, oh,
I'll just be my own boss
and do it from the start, but
actually you do learn a lot
working for other people
and especially in a large
company that's become established.
It makes you more humble in one element.
And it also helps you get
an understanding of how
large companies work.
Because if you're just
a career entrepreneur,
and there's nothing wrong
with that, if you're only
used to, kind of, being the
boss and working for yourself
and working in small
teams, when it gets to that
stage where you really
need to scale, I feel that
a lot of earners do fall
down and you have cases
where the original founders
of a place by outside CEO's
and outside chairmans, exedra,
because they're not ready to
run a company of that size.
They don't have the skill
set to take it from a
small group of people to a
much, much larger organization.
The next five years we're
hoping to really make a
big impact in the
venture capital industry,
work with really exciting
companies, and help
grow them to the stage
where they can either
(background laughter)
exit to trade sell or go
to IPA, that's a dream.
And we're looking to
really help create the next
game changing, innovative companies in
technology space.
Particularly out of Europe.
That's one thing I'm particularly
passionate about, too.
Catching up with the whole kind of
entrepreneurshipsy in the
U.S. and Silicon Valley,
and that's one thing I'm really hoping to
see the next big unicorns
coming out of Europe.
(dramatic music)